the world explodes when wall street
journal columnist says dr joe biden
should drop the honorific
the supreme court rejects trump's texas
case and vaccine distribution begins in
the united states i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
slash ben will get to all the news in
just one month the electoral college
obviously
votes today will bring all the details
on how that works and what is likely to
happen but
before we get to that let me just remind
you the best holiday gift as
always meet the steak okay so omaha
steaks how do i know they're so good
because i keep kosher and because i'm a
special person they actually sent me a
kosher steak let me tell you
this is the most tender juicy delicious
steak i have ever cooked it is just
spectacular omaha steaks it's over 100
years old founded in 1917
still a fifth generation family-owned
company truly the definition of the
american dream
send the perfect gift this holiday
season or send yourself something
special
bring families together for a delicious
omaha steak holiday feast
the deluxe griller's assortment features
butcher's cut filet mignons a vast
variety of entrees
sides and desserts and here is exactly
what is in the deluxe griller's
assortment are you ready for this
four top sirloins eight boneless chicken
breasts four omaha steaks burgers eight
gourmet jumbo franks
eight individual scalloped potatoes
eight caramel apple tartlets and one
signature seasoning jar
i mean that is some solid stuff right
now you get that incredible package plus
four free burgers and a free digital
meat thermometer at an exclusive price
available only to my listeners go to
omahastakes.com enter that code shapiro
into the search bar
if you're not hungry just listening to
this particular advertisement i have not
done my job because let me just tell you
this stuff is mouth-watering it is juicy
it is going to make your evening
or an evening of your friends family
members go check them out right now
omahasteaks.com
type shapiro into the search bar and
shop the best gourmet gifts of the
season again go to omahasteaks.com go to
the search bar and type in
my name shapiro to find the best gourmet
gifts of the season okay so we'll get to
everything
election 2020 related in just one moment
plus everything coveted related but
i'd be remiss if i did not note the big
stupid controversy of the weekend so the
big stupid controversy of the weekend
is there is an article that i found
highly amusing i'll just say it right
now it's a funny article by joseph
epstein who used to write for commentary
magazine among other things
he wrote a piece in the wall street
journal titled is there a doctor in the
white house
not if you need an md jill biden should
think about dropping the honorific which
feels fraudulent even comic okay
fat check true fact check true okay
let's be real about this
dr joe biden is not a doctor in any
sense you would actually
need a doctor okay i've had this debate
many times publicly for a long time this
has nothing to do with actually
jill biden as a human being here is my
view when it comes to doctorate degrees
okay i am a lawyer which means i am a
jurist doctor
if i were to suggest that anyone call me
doctor like dr shapiro because i am a jd
you would think that i was an ass okay
and you'd be right
because that's an ass thing to do okay
there was a guy who lived around the
corner from us many many years ago
he got his phd in musicology and i'm
sure he worked very hard on that
dissertation
in musicology but let me just tell you
if you're at a dinner party
and somebody had said you know what's
your name and he said dr smith and then
later in dinner
he had some sort of anaphylactic
reaction to the food
and dr smith had been called to the
table
because he had to do something and they
said oh yeah and what's your doctor in
he said musicology
i guarantee you the person dying had
been very very disappointed to learn
that it was a doctorate in musicology if
you're ever on a plane this happened
before because
as everyone knows my wife is an actual
doctor meaning a medical doctor meaning
somebody who can take care of you if you
have a medical issue
if you're ever on a plane and the pilot
says do we have a doctor on board
if you raise your hand because you're a
doctor of gender studies you're an
asshat
you're not helpful you're not a helpful
human being there's a vast distinction
between people who are medical doctors
and people who are everything else now
if you want to be pedantic about this
and say yes dr joe well she has a phd
okay you want to call her professor joe
biden that makes more sense right if she
teaches or something i mean it's phd
right that's what we typically do
but the suggestion that somebody is dr
jill biden
and that she has no compe by the way her
doctorate is in education
which not to crap on the field of
education but to crap a little bit on
the field of education
if you went to if you got like your
doctorate in education
i'm sorry that is not even in the same
ballpark as even like
a jd let alone a an md
or or a phd in maths and hard sciences
okay i'm a liberal arts guy which means
my degrees
mean so much less than anybody who's in
mathematics or physics
let alone medicine where you actually
take care of people and try to make sure
that they are okay physically okay the
reason that this comes up is again
because people get confused about dr
jill biden because everybody insists in
the media i'm calling her doctor jill
because wow she has a she has a graduate
degree
a graduate degree again as a person with
a graduate degree
let me just say graduate degrees they
don't mean squat they don't
okay i'm crapping on my own degree right
now and i went to harvard law school
and yes it doesn't mean a whole hell of
a lot it means that you're smart enough
to get a degree
congrats but i'm sorry if you got a
doctorate in education
because you wrote a paper called i'm not
kidding you this is dr joe biden's
dissertation at the university of
delaware
okay it is called student retention at
the community college level
meeting students needs wow
groundbreaking content analysis content
analysis
of student college needs at uh at
community colleges
and you insist that everybody call you
doctor this is no less irritating than
when barbara boxer
was uh was grilling somebody from the
military and he called her
mrs boxer or something she said it's
senator it's okay if you insist on you
first of all you've never met a medical
doctor who does that if you have to
insist on your honorific it's because
you're being a douchebag i don't care
whether you're man whether you're a
woman that's the way it works if you
insist on your honorific
because you're insulted that nobody
calls you by your honorific
you're a douche okay i've met at this
point hundreds
probably thousands of doctors okay not
one of them has ever if
we're introduced not one of them if i
say mr x has ever said no it's doctor
it's only some schmuck who has a degree
in classics who's like no no
it's doctor okay because they want you
to respect and agree well guess what
tough tough noogies anyway so this guy
joseph epstein he writes a piece
saying that dr jill biden should stop
calling herself dr joe biden because
it's giving people the impression that
she actually knows things about medicine
which of course she does not
by the way if you think that that's a
fictitious thing whoopi goldberg
suggested
that joe biden make her surgeon general
hey sir what's she going to do educate
your arm
like oh i'm going to i'm going to teach
i'm going to teach about the educational
strategies with regard to
cancer analysis good stuff there
so yes it is deliberately confusing what
again it's a normal thing
in america that if somebody says they're
a doctor we assume that they're a
medical doctor and if you want to be
pedantic content anxious about this
then yes you can call somebody a doctor
if they got their degree in queer dance
theory
but it is not the same thing and
everybody knows it's not the same thing
and all this really
is okay everybody's response to this
which we'll get to in a second
everybody's response to this
is basically a way for them just to
claim that you're a misogynist if you
don't want to call dr jill biden a
doctor even though i would not call a
man with a degree in education a doctor
in any case in any case i'm sorry i'm
i'm not impressed by your degree i'm not
impressed by the scroll upon which
somebody has written a university name
and i have many of those girls i am not
impressed by any of that stuff i'm
impressed by what you do for a living
i'm impressed by the fact that doctors
especially in this time it's so funny
that this has become such an issue now
because
just going to point out in this time
when we should be appreciating medical
doctors more than perhaps any time in
american history when medical doctors
are on the front lines
trying to save lives in the middle of a
global pandemic for people to be like
yes and we should also call doctor this
person who wrote a dissertation
about the need for better funding at
your local juco is like
all right guys all right i get the
feeling that this might be a setup
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because the original article is
funny and then people lose their minds
because everyone is stupid we'll get to
that in just one moment first
have you ever been frustrated the fact
you're scrolling through your phone and
you look on your phone and there's a
bunch of great photos of your family
but you've completely forgotten about
them right they're like a year old two
years old you never did anything with
them you sort of lived in the cloud you
assumed that one day you would do
something with them
what if you could take that photo send
it in to a service and they would
immediately send you back that photo
in a beautiful format i'm talking about
like on metal glass wood or more this is
what myphoto.com does it's game changing
it's really easy and really fast you can
take any photo
and make it into a metal glass wood
creation it literally takes two minutes
to do you get it in five days it comes
in a stunning gift box with the holidays
coming up it makes a fantastic holiday
gifts especially for people you can't
get together with
this year these guys have literally made
millions of customers memories come to
life
it's amazing go to myphoto.com you can
easily see your photo on all their
products and then
you simply hit purchase and use promo
code ben 25 today for 25
off i know the folks who own the company
wonderful wonderful people go to
myphoto.com right now use that code
ben25
get 25 off you'll see how easy and fun
it is it can actually be addicting you
can fill your home with beautiful photos
at the touch of a button
it's really easy and fast go check them
out right now myphoto.com and use that
code ben25
get 25 percent off okay so here is what
this editorial said this op-ed said by
joseph epstein and said
madame first lady mrs biden jill kiddo a
bit of advice on what may seem like a
small but i think is not
an important matter any chance you might
drop the doctor before your name
dr joe biden sounds and feels fraudulent
not to say a touch comic your degree is
i believe
an edd a doctor of education earned at
the university of delaware through a
dissertation with the unpromising titles
student retention at the community
college level meeting students needs
a wise man once said that no one should
call himself doctor unless he has
delivered a child
think about it dr jill and fourth with
drop the doc okay so people are mad
because
he's sneering sneering at joe biden if
she insists on being called dr joe biden
i join in the sneering if you insist on
being called doctor
because you got a doctorate in divinity
i'm i'm with i'm with them okay and i i
you know he says kiddo wow he said kiddo
well yes i'm sure he would say that to a
dude as well okay this is not about
sex it's not about misogyny i understand
that everything on the left has to be
massaged
into some sort of charge of sexism
racism bigotry or homophobia
but i'm sorry telling a telling a
a white lady in her in her late 60s
that she should stop calling herself
doctor because she is
not an actual medical doctor that is not
sexist it's not
just because she happens to first of all
i don't even know the charge sexes and
makes sense anymore from the left
considering that they believe a man can
be a woman
or a woman can be a man but even if you
were to assume that it makes sense now
i'm just wondering exactly why it would
be sexist to say that anybody
anybody at all should not be called the
doctor unless they are an actual medical
doctor by the way this came up when i
was at harvard law there was a there was
a um
and i'll keep dropping that reference
because if you're not impressed by
harvard law then you certainly should
not be impressed by a degree from
university of delaware in education
in any case i remember when i was at
harvard law in actual prestigious law
school
okay and i'm not impressed by it you
shouldn't be impressed by it either
a professor one day was in the class and
a student
raised he was a woman she raised her
hand and
she was called upon and the professor
did not mention her honorific okay it
turned out that she had a doctorate
in some classics field or something and
one of the other students said you
should call her doctor
and the professor immediately responded
if i have a heart attack can she help
and she said no he said that i'm not
calling her doctor agree
agree okay according to according to
this columnist i taught at northwestern
university for 30 years without a
doctorate or any advanced degree
i have only a ba in absentia from the
university of chicago in absentia
because i took my examination on a pool
table at headquarters company fort hood
texas while serving in the peacetime
army in the late 50s
i do have an honorary doctorate though i
have to report the president of the
school that awarded it was fired the
year after i received it
not i hope for allowing my honorary
doctorate during my years as a
university teacher i was sometimes
addressed usually on the phone as dr
epstein on such occasions it was all i
could do not to reply read two chapters
of henry james and get into bed i'll be
right over
i was also often addressed as doctor
during the years i was editor of the
american scholar the quarterly magazine
of phi beta kappa
let me quickly insert i'm also not a
member of phi beta kappa except by
marriage
many of those who so addressed me i
noted were scientists i also received a
fair amount of correspondence from
people who appended the letters
phd to their names atop their
letterheads and have twice seen phd on
vanity license plates which struck me as
pathetic
in contemporary university in the social
sciences and humanities calling oneself
doctor is thought bush league
okay and then he talks about how how
we've kind of watered down the degree
and honorary doctorates are also
watering down the degrees
he points out that honorary degree
recipients and commencement speakers
have included people like stephen
colbert and seth meyers
he says political correctness has put
paid to any true honor an
honorary doctorate may once have
possessed if you are ever looking for a
simile to denote rarity try rarer than a
contemporary university honorary degree
list not containing an african-american
woman then there are all those honorary
degrees bestowed on bill cosby charlie
rose and others who
owing to their proven or alleged sexual
predations have had to be rescinded
as for your edd madam first lady harder
though it may have been please consider
stowing it at least in public at least
for now
forget the small thrill of being dr jill
and settle for the larger thrill of
living for the next four years in the
best public housing in the world is
first lady
jill biden okay so it's supposed to be a
funny
little piece right this thing blows up
and people lose their minds because
how dare you how
dare you dr jill biden created the
vaccine that is going to cure covet 19.
wait no she didn't do that dr jill biden
could take out your appendix if you had
a
nope dr joe biden could probably
even act as a psychologist oh dr joe
biden has her degree in math
nope no okay so that people are getting
offended for no reason because who cares
first of all who cares
second of all it's a funny piece third
of all he happens to be right you
shouldn't call yourself doctor man woman
or frog
whether you happen to have unless you
happen to have an actual
degree in medical science period end of
story
again has been my heart and fast
position for a very long time i might
michael mull's wife
has a phd in something or other i don't
even remember what
and i've mocked knowles for years about
this i've said i've said to knows over
and over and over that my doctor is
my wife is a real doctor his wife is not
a real doctor fact check true
okay so any case people lose their minds
but here's where it gets wild
here's where it gets wild okay so
michael larosa
is the spokesperson for jill biden
previously
at dr biden spokes and traveling press
by the way that is her actual twitter
handle
dr biden she's not a medical doctor
she isn't and as somebody who watched my
wife go through and helped her through
like a million years of school and
residency
and leaving home at odd hours so that
she could go to the hospital and treat
patients
let me just say that anyone who equates
a doctorate in education to a medical
doctorate is an idiot a fool and a
in any case she her handle is at dr
biden
okay and here's what michael here's what
michael larosa tweets
at james toronto who is the editor of
the wall street journal op-ed page
you and the w and the wall street
journal should be embarrassed to print
the disgusting
sexist attack on dr biden running in the
wall street journal opinion page if you
had any respect for women at all
you would remove this repugnant display
of chauvinism from your paper
and apologize to her okay so just a note
that is the spokesperson
for the supposed incoming first lady of
the united states who
is openly calling for an op-ed page to
attract an op-ed
you know normally as the editor of a or
editor-emeritus of a major publication
let me just point out normally when you
retract something it's because of
factual errors you don't retract opinion
pieces
i'm amazed amazed that the same people
who are fine with the new york times
running full-on op-eds from chinese
propaganda outlets
running full-on op-eds about the glories
of sex under socialism in eastern
germany which is something the new york
times did
not all that long ago that these same
people are like
you said dr jill biden should stop
calling herself doctor
how dare you sir take down this
disgusting sexist
slur and what's amazing the media agreed
because our media they love the first
amendment and they are really upset with
attacks on the press unless of course
the attacks on the president being made
by democrats in which
in which case they're over in the corner
going
like tom holtz and amadeus doug emhoff
who is the husband of kamala harris
he wrote dr biden earned her degrees
through hard work and pure grit
pure grit it's an education degree from
the university of delaware i'm sorry
jordan out on the railroads you know
like
pure grit she was again university of
delaware
earning a degree in education not the
same
like did she work herself up from the
slums
to get an education degree at the
university of delaware wow what a rags
to rich's story that is
i mean that's like those tales of people
back in the 1800s who like
get on there covered wagons make their
way out west build log cabins with their
own hands i mean that
pure grit when i think grit i think
pioneers and a lady who got an education
doctorate from university of delaware
grit
she earned her degrees through hard work
and pure grit she's an inspiration to me
to her students and to americans across
the country
i mean
well see
this story would never have been written
about a man said doug hoff well that's
not true
that's a 100 not true let's say that
newt gingrich had insisted that people
call him dr gingrich because gingrich
has a phd in history if he did that
how many people do you think would write
op-eds mocking him for that
one million upper like what's the upper
boundary on is there an upper boundary
people who have not yet been born
would mock newt gingrich for that if if
a republic if a republican had a had a
professorship
in some other form of work and insisted
on being called doctor
the mockery would never end but you've
got charlotte climber
who's uh who's again this this liberal
activist who very often can be found in
the op-ed pages of these major
newspapers
writing in light of that wsj op-ed on dr
joe biden what a stunning coincidence
that comparatively uncredentialed white
men only seem to get up their hackles
without phds
being referred to as doctors when it's a
woman and or person of color using that
honorific
what a striking happenstance and yet
what also a depressing irony when so
many women and or physicians have
having related have related having their
md credentials doubted or assumed to be
less than credentials and medical
the social justice crap that just spills
from the mouths of these people is
unreal
it's unreal okay so here's what here's
the amazing part of all of this
so what happens next what happens next
year
so northwestern university then condemns
epstein
so just going to point out that people
with doctorates who the new york times
doesn't refer to
by their actual by their actual
honorifics here's just a list this is
put out by
uh sunny mcsunny face it's only right
over at twitter and this happens to be
correct newt gingrich tammy duckworth
madeleine albright david petraeus h.r
mcmaster ben sasse kirsten cinema
sebastian gorka henry kissinger alan
greenspan conor lisa rice
robert gates james schlesinger ash
carter big neil brzezinski ben bernanke
tony evers gina roman raymondo
william perry shaq also has an honorary
degree neil degrasse tyson
norman borlaug they've even called dr
ben carson justin ben carson the new
york times
circa 2017. like dr ben carson is an
actual medical neurosurgeon
and they call him just ben carson but
it's very bad guys super super bad but
here's the thing
how is all this reacted to not with the
usual rolling of eyes that would be
sort of normal over all of this but
instead
people react like they're right make the
wall street journal and joseph epstein
pay
this is the part where it becomes sort
of an important issue like the rest of
this is just sort of dumb
but it becomes an important issue when
all of a sudden you start seeing the
cancel culture coming for people who say
something as
as frankly plain to see
as the only people who should generally
be called doctors in american lives are
people who can
take care of you if you break your leg
we'll get to more of this in just
one second first let us talk
about the fact that you've been putting
off straightening those teeth so long
time ago you had those braces right
and then you took off the braces a
glorious day finally you went to school
everybody's like wow where'd the braces
go
and your orthodontist warned you on the
way out wear this retainer and you did
you wore it for like six months and then
you flushed it down the toilet oops it's
gone
and now it's 20 years later and your
teeth have slipped out of place but you
don't want to put back on the braces
you're not in middle school
so i have a solution for you candid
clear aligners they're comfortable
removable practically invisible unlike
wear braces
so you can transform your smile without
anybody noticing plus your treatment is
prescribed and monitored remotely by a
licensed orthodontist who's an expert in
tooth movement
it's all done from the comfort and
convenience of your own home cans it
only works with orthodontist never
general dentists like other companies
plus your supervising orthodontist will
be with you every step of the way with
candid your treatment includes remote
monitoring by the same orthodontist who
created your plan
so you never have to wonder how you're
doing you'll always know which is great
the average candid treatment just six
months you'll start seeing results way
before then it costs thousands of
dollars less than braces
start straightening your teeth today
right now all my listeners can save 75
bucks on candids at starter kit go to
candidco.com
shapiro use code shapiro that is candid
co.com
shapiro use code shapiro take advantage
of this limited time offer to save 75
bucks on your starter kit candidco.com
shapiro use code shapiro right now okay
so here's where it gets wild
so it's not just the people get on
epstein's case which you know you want
to get on his case a free country
the northwestern university where he
taught for like 30 years
they put out a condemnation a
condemnation of him
now i can imagine other northwestern
university grads having done worse
things than saying
that a person calling themselves doctor
for a doctorate in education
is stupid but northwestern university
reserves their ire
for joseph epstein here's what they put
out according to the campus editor at
daley northwestern
northwestern condemned the opinions
expressed by former english lecturer
joseph epstein
in a viral wall street journal piece on
dr joe biden's doctor title
and you while supporting academic
freedom and freedom of expression wrote
in a saturday statement and does not
agree with epstein's opinions laid out
in the op-ed
the university emphasized a doctoral
designation is well deserved by any
individual
who has earned a phd md or in biden's
case in edd
northwestern is firmly committed to
equity diversity and inclusion
and strongly disagrees with mr epstein's
misogynistic views i have a question
what's misogynistic about that
seriously somebody has yet to explain
why it's misogynistic
just i understand joe biden's a woman or
self-identifies as such which is the way
democrats do this thing
these days but i do not understand what
is misogynistic about that view
it is completely sex neutral if if a
doctor
of of whatever random liberal arts
a doctor of film insisted on calling
himself doctor we would all laugh at him
and rightly so
nu's english department said the op-ed
cast an unmerited aspersion
on biden's doctoral credentials and
expertise rejecting the opinion the
department wrote it also condemns the
diminishing of any individual's
well-earned degrees in any field from
any university
well i mean if that's your standard that
i can't mock anybody's degree well then
i think your standard is stupid
by the way worth noting apparently
northwestern university actually removed
epstein from their website they actually
like took down his profile from their
website
so they they weren't just they weren't
canceling him but they were a little
canceling him
meanwhile the washington post ran a
piece by monica hess
one of their columnists titled i kid you
not the wall street journal column about
joel biden is worse than you thought
my god worse than i even thought
well i mean i i thought it was i thought
it was like the worst thing
since basically mineconf now you're
telling me it's even worse than that
what could possibly be worse than that
but i mean my thoughts on that that i
bought
i thought it was the worst thing i'd
ever read like i thought it was worse
honestly i thought it was significantly
worse than ibum kendi like it was the
worst thing i've ever read
and i i don't know what to say if it's
even worse than that
what what will we do here's how monica
hess opens
her idiotic piece of the washington post
in one of my favorite episodes of the
west wing
abigail bartlett a trained surgeon and
fictional first lady
speaks with a white house attorney about
a looming scandal the lawyer addresses
her as mrs bartlett to which she stopped
to which she responds with the iciest
correction dr bartlett
okay so first of all just a quick note
if you start your washington post
article by quoting the west wing for
your source of expertise i'm not going
to listen to you anymore because you're
stupid
done end of story this is the scene i
went searching for on netflix after
reading an exceptionally bad column
in the wall street journal and then if
you witnessed online
outrage about this column it was
probably over these aforementioned
paragraphs let's dispense with them
quickly there's nothing comical about
toiling for years to achieve a
credential that is technically and
socially correct for joe biden
it's a little funny it's a little funny
the fact that she accomplished this
later in life
is admirable the title of her
dissertation sounds important and not
unpromising
okay so okay so everybody loses it right
okay and and finally the wall street
journal responds to this
so the wall street journal puts out a
piece by paul jagot
and paul shigo is the journal's
editorial page editor
and he says joe biden says it is time to
heal america's divisions after the trump
presidency and the wall street journal
has praised him for saying so
presumably he intends less rancor with
the press as part of this mandate on
that score my run in with the biden team
this weekend was very trumpian
the catalyst was our saturday op-ed by
joseph epstein
this has triggered a flood of media and
twitter criticism including demands i
retract this piece apologize personally
to mrs biden banned mr epstein for all
time and resign and think upon my sins
the complaints began as a trickle but
became a torrent after the biden media
team elevated mr epstein's work in what
was clearly a political strategy
elizabeth alexander the soon-to-be first
lady's communications director said
sexist and shameful be better wall
street journal okay so first of all
anytime somebody says be better kiss my
ass that should always be the immediate
response
if somebody says be better yeah stick it
where the sun don't shine sideways
mrs alexander miss alexander called me
after her tweet to register her
disapproval personally which is fine her
job is to flack for her boss part of my
job is to listen to complaints we had a
frank exchange reviews as the diplomats
say i invited her to send in a letter
for publication
meanwhile team biden continued to push
the sexist theme doug emhoff
husband of kamala harris tweeted dr
biden earned her degrees through hard
work and pure grit
pete buddha judge's husband jason booty
judge tweeted the author could have used
fewer words to just say
you know in my day we didn't have to
respect women
oh my god
yeah thank you chasing buddha judge
needed that
why go to such length to highlight a
single op-ed on a relatively minor issue
my guess is that the biden team
concluded it was a chance to use the big
gun of identity politics to send a
message to critics as it prepares to
take power there's nothing like playing
the race or gender card to stifle
criticism
it's the left's version of donald
trump's enemy of the people tweets says
the wall street journal op-ed editor the
difference is that when mr trump rants
against the press the press
mobilizes in opposition in this case the
biden team was able to mobilize almost
all of the press to join ins announcing
mr epstein in the journal
nearly every publication wrote about the
biden's response reinforcing the biden
new york times line
in opinion writer argued jill biden
should drop the doctor few
were swayed this strategy worked to
protect joe and hundreds during the
campaign it's no surprise they're
keeping it up as they head to the white
house
northwestern university did its part by
denouncing him and appearing to purchase
emeritus listing from the website
this is how canceled culture works the
outrage
is overwrought because whether you agree
or disagree epstein's piece was fair
comment the issue of jill biden's
educational honorific isn't new
as long ago as 2009 the l.a times
devoted a story to the subject from a
piece by robin abakarian joe biden on
the campaign trail explained his wife's
desire for the highest degree was in
response to what she perceived as her
second-class status on their mail she
said i was so sick of the mail coming to
senator and mrs biden i wanted to get
mail address to doctor and senator biden
that's the real reason she got her
doctorate he said first of all if that's
the real reason you got your doctorate
that's the douchiest reason i've ever
heard
you're offended by your mail no one what
like seriously my wife did not get a
medical degree so that it would say mr
and dr shapiro
on the mail okay and as somebody who's
quite proud of the fact that my wife got
her degree like oh where around
the ucla medicine like she's never worn
a harvard law
gear thing i wear around ucla medical
here like all the time because i'm proud
of my wife for doing what she has done
okay she didn't become a doctor so that
she could put it on the mail in fact i
asked her about this last night
and my doctor and my doctor wife
immediately said i don't care about that
if somebody call me mrs shapiro as
opposed to doctor you think i care
i know what i do for a living why would
i care about that
i mean she also added first of all my
first my first identity is actually not
as my job my first identity
is as a mother and a wife but beyond
that like why would i care about that if
you're so insecure that you need
everybody to call you doctor when you
don't actually you're not even a medical
doctor
then i'm not to tell you seriously many
readers according to the wall street
journal's paul chago said mr epstein's
use of kiddo is demeaning but then joe
biden is also fond of that locution
in his 2012 democratic convention speech
he even used it to refer to his wife
mr epstein also infuriated dozens of
educators defending their doctorates
but that statuses and sacrosanct are out
of bounds for debate mr epstein's point
applies to men and women
his peacema also mocked men for their
honorary degrees mrs biden is now
america's most prominent doctorate
holder and is taking a leading role in
education policy she can't be off-limits
for commentary
by the way the journal editorial page's
long-time style is to use doctor only
when referring to medical doctors
henry kissinger gets a mister lynn
chaney wife of dick cheney is mrs cheney
despite her phd
if you disagree with abstinent fair
enough write a letter or shout your
objections on twitter
the pages aren't going to stop
publishing provocative essays merely
because they offend the new
administration or the political censors
in the media and academia see this is
where it gets ugly okay so the fact is
as we've been talking about for a very
long time it is not that the media are
pro free speech it is not that the media
are in favor of freedom of the press
it's that the media are in favor of
their ability to say whatever they want
to say so long as it is leftist and
everybody else should shut the hell up
this ties into a broader narrative that
really does have some comp does have
some implications
for broader national politics we'll get
to more of that in just one second
first let us discuss a wonderful
wonderful holiday gift i'm talking about
the gift of jewelry
so i get my wife jewelry on as many
holidays as i can possibly
afford and let me just tell you one of
the places i go to most is the pearl
source why
because at the pearl source you get the
highest quality pearl jewelry at up to
seventy percent
off retail prices and it is just
beautiful stuff i have a pro necklace
for my pearl earrings from my
we got from the pearl source it's
beautiful wonderful stuff and you are
getting
a steep steep discount off of sticker
price if you were to just go to some
sort of perl store
why well that's because the pearl source
cuts out the middle man by eliminating
traditional five times markups by
jewelry stores and selling directly to
you
the consumer shop safely and securely
from the comfort of your home at the
pearl source you'll find the largest
selection of pearls available anywhere
each jewelry piece is custom made for
you customize your jewelry based on
pearl size quality gold type length
and many more choices the holidays are
fast approaching and shipping carriers
have an unprecedented amount of volume
so don't wait
the pearl source offers fast and free
two-day shipping on every order zero
contact delivery
everything comes beautifully packaged in
that elegant jewelry box it's ready to
be given as a gift and
if you're not sure if she's gonna love
your pick no worries pearl source comes
with a no hassle 60 day
money back guarantee so it is risk-free
i know the people who run the pearl
source they are incredibly honest
wonderful wonderful family people go to
the pearlsource.com ben enter promo code
ben at checkout and get 20
off your entire order today again if you
want fine pearl jewelry at the best
prices online go straight to the source
the pearl source that's
thepearlsource.com and for promo code
ben at checkout okay so
this ties into a broader conversation
about the media's attempts to quash
other members of the media there's a
long article
in buzzfeed over the weekend talking
about how people at facebook
are very upset why are they so upset
they're upset because facebook isn't
shutting down enough opinion now the
establishment and legacy media rely on a
monopoly
they rely on their monopoly over the
distribution of information they are
angry that facebook broke that monopoly
and now they want facebook to reimpose
that monopoly from the tops there's this
long article in buzzfeed from ryan mack
and craig silverman
after the us election key people are
leaving facebook and torching the
company in departure nights
okay quick quick answer to this as a
person who heads a company with over 100
employees
yeah don't let the door hit you on the
way out seriously if you want to quit
and write me a nasty note about how you
don't like working here
tough padookies i don't care and
facebook should treat it the same way
they're one of the biggest companies on
planet earth but they're supposed to be
concerned because some woke staffer is
mad at them
apparently the answer is yes according
to buzzfeed on wednesday a facebook data
scientist departed the social networking
company after a two-year stint
leaving a farewell note for their
colleagues to ponder as part of the team
focused on violence and incitement they
dealt with some of the worst content on
facebook and they were proud of their
work at the company
despite this they said facebook was
simply not doing
enough wow with so many internal forces
propping up the production
of hateful and violent content the task
of stopping hate and violence on
facebook
starts to feel even more sicifian than
it already is the employee wrote
in their badge post a traditional
farewell note for any departing facebook
employee
it also makes it embarrassing to work
here embarrassing
so what sorts of things are they really
angry at apparently
they're very angry they're very very
angry that
there are a bunch of conservative
websites that are getting traffic using
data from a facebook tool called the
hate bait dashboard which can track
content from groups and pages
that leads to hateful interactions the
data scientists listed the 10 us pages
with the largest concentrated volume of
likely violating hate speech comments in
the past 14 days
so they're not actually saying that the
content from these websites is hateful
they're saying that people might post
hateful content under the content
okay which we don't control so here wait
for it you ready
all pages were associated with
conservative outlets or personalities
including breitbart news fox news the
daily caller donald trump's campaign and
main accounts and ben shapiro
ah there it is they also shared a sample
of the hateful comments posted on a
recent breitbart news post
about nancy pelosi's support for
transgender athletes
wow those are that's driving the hate
speech you see if you put up stories
that people are not covering in the
mainstream media and then people comment
in nasty ways that's the fault of people
putting up stories that we just didn't
want to hear
so the the media have been openly
stumping for
the shutdown of free speech there's
another article from the guardian over
the weekend
a woman named ariel bogle could be a man
i'm not sure actually
ariel is ariel can be both a male and
female name
uh in any case ariel bogle writes
sinister sounds
podcasts are becoming the new medium of
disinformation see any
any alternative source of information
will come
under fire anyone and all you have to do
the sin does not have to be grave
all the sin has to be is saying
something like dr joe biden is not an
actual medical doctor
or that men exist and women exist and
they are separate entities
that mammalian species are are sexually
dichotomous
to say such things brings the ire of the
woke upon you
and all methods of distribution
unapproved by the establishment legacy
media
must be shut down so we've got buzzfeed
trying to push facebook to shut down
publications like daily wire or daily
caller or breitbart or anyplace else on
the right
and now they're coming after podcasts so
you have this entire article in the
guardian
that is very very angry why are they so
angry they're angry because
because joe rogan exists apps such as
apple and google podcast are significant
gatekeepers of what kind of audio
content reaches our ears says evelyn
dueck a lecturer at harvard law school
although they function more as
directories for organizing and
discovering shows than in social
networking platforms and have varying
degrees of oversight and control
podcasts can serve as an entry point at
a point of legitimation for unfounded
claims
says dr sarah roberts an associate
professor at ucla and a moderation
expert
the net effect is not only to put fake
bogus and debunked claims into the
larger public conversation but to shift
the needle entirely on the public's
attention in areas of concern
most podcast platforms already have
content policies apple prohibits the
promotion
of violence spotify bans content that
incites hatred based on race or gender
identity
among other things but the adequacy of
these policies not to mention if or how
they are enforced remains opaque
especially if the problematic content is
espoused by a programmed guest
rather than the host and this is a
problem because it's a pedestal it can
be a pedestal
for bad views guys and so we need to
stop all of this podcasting we need to
stop all this interneting we need to
stop freedom of information
see this is the part that's scary yeah
all these all these
people in the media who are saying that
trump was a threat to the freedom of the
press no you guys are the threats of the
freedom
of the press you are your threats to the
freedom of the press freedom to strip
distribution of information and content
you don't like you will attack podcasts
if you think the podcasting
becomes a popular source of alternative
information you'll attack facebook for
even allowing the distribution of
alternative sources of information
okay th this is ideological fascism
in effect is not saying fascism as in
top-down government system
but the culture of free speech requires
more than a legal commitment to free
speech
it requires a cultural commitment to
free speech i have never called for pod
save america to come down
from these podcasting platforms i
guarantee you folks on the left within
minutes we'll be calling for this
podcast to come down
from podcasting platforms yeah i've
never called
for huffington post to be restricted in
its reach
at facebook but the new york times has
an entire column
several columnists dedicated to the
proposition that
daily wire should be restricted in its
reach on facebook ranging from charlie
warzell to kevin roose to karis wisher
the the kind of push in the media for
everybody in the media to
mirror the perspectives of the left is
pretty damned obvious
it's pretty obvious and this is why they
because
here's the thing so long as no
alternative suppose they can continue to
present their objective
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact
that during this pandemic businesses
have had to move
they've had to shift they have to pivot
you have to be flexible from working
remotely to pivoting your business model
for long-term survival and growth
if you're in charge of hiring for your
business pivots have made it your job
even more challenging especially if you
have to hire for brand new roles
thankfully there's one place you can
always count on to make hiring
faster and easier ziprecruiter.com
dailywire
when you post a job on zip recruiter it
gets sent out to over 100 top job boards
with one click
then zip recruiter's powerful technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job and then
actively invites them
to apply it's no wonder that four out of
five employers who post unzip recruiter
get a quality candidate
within the very first day if you're
looking to upgrade your employees then
you should be looking to zipper crew
let's say you have an employee
who is so annoying and so bad that
you've been trying to fire him for years
in fact let's say you moved a hundred
person company out of the town where he
lived
just to avoid him and then he followed
you like a lost dog from homeward bound
and let's say that you just wanted to
get rid of the spirit let's say that
this person had the bizarre perspective
until the last five minutes
that doctor is an honorific that should
be applied to pretty much everybody who
earns a doctorate as opposed to just
medical doctors and you're like you know
what i don't like that guy anymore i
want to get rid of him
zip recruiter would be the place to go
yes i'm speaking about michael moles
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire.ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
let zip recruiter take hiring off your
plate so you can focus on growing your
business go to ziprecruiter.com
daily wirez it recruiters indeed the
smartest way to hire
i'll get to more of this in just one
second first on monday sept december
21st the historical docu-series apollo
what we saw will soon be available
exclusively at dailywire.com originally
released as an audio podcast for apple
and spotify
what we saw will be available to watch
as well as listen on the daily wire
apple tv or roku app or at dailywire.com
the docu-series takes a detailed look at
the apollo 11 mission to land a man on
the moon
it was the culmination of a heated
decades-long space race between cold war
rivals the us and the soviet union
the podcast explores one of america's
greatest accomplishments through the
eyes of the millions of americans who
lived through it
it's really fantastic it's a great piece
of work a dramatically inspiring story
apollo 11 what we saw it's a fantastic
series to watch with your loved ones
over the holiday break right now
get it for 20 off with code watch when
you become an insider or above member
over at dailywire.com
subscribe make sure to download our
apple tv or roku app to get all of our
content
on your big screen including our podcast
and special live streams like our
upcoming christmas edition of backstage
yes that is the thing that is happening
that's dailywire.com
subscribe to get 20 off your membership
with codewatch and
access to all of our new and existing
content you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so again the purpose here of
restricting alternative sources of
information
is not only to create a market monopoly
in which you can only view one side of
the aisle
it's to re-establish the idea that if
you're a leftist you're actually
objective
because if there's no other side of the
aisle then you can promote yourself as
objective this is what members of the
establishment media did
for literally decades right walter
cronkite a motivated leftist and sam
donaldson a motivated leftist and rather
a motivated leftist and these were the
these were your news anchors the people
you were supposed to believe and because
there was no real alternative source of
information in real time
it meant that they could get away with
as much political bias as they wanted to
ladle into their programming
and this is how you have idiots like
chris cuomo who ends up being perceived
as somehow somehow objective journalist
here's what chris cuomo tweeted
objective journalist chris cuomo just
journalism all over the place that hot
sticky journalism getting everywhere he
tweeted
with trump saying we just begun to fight
when it just ended this is actually
barely parody
he's talking about an snl sketch making
fun of newsmax they did a sketch
called sports max in which uh people
refuse to admit the jets ever lose
it the description is actually funnier
than the sketch was in any case uh chris
cuomo
tweeted out with trump saying we just
begun to fight when it just ended this
is actually barely parody we need to
remember the retroplicants at their
worst
and strive to hold all those in power to
a much much much higher standard lest we
wind up here again
yes speaking truth to power that's
something that chris cuomo does on a
regular basis while making jokes about
his brother's nostril size as tens of
thousands of people die in his brother's
state
yes chris cuomo that's that's a dude who
speaks truth to power i really look
forward to chris cuomo's interview with
andrew cuomo
about the latest sexual harassment
allegations against his brother
yeah i have a feeling that's not going
to come up ryan's of edward reporting
over the weekend
sexual misconduct allegations were
alleged against new york democrat
governor andrew cuomo on sunday
a development that comes alongside news
that joe biden reportedly considered
cuomo to be attorney general
the allegations against cuomo were made
by one of his former advisors
progressive activist lindsay boylan
boylan made the allegation on twitter in
a series of tweets on her exp on her
experience
with sexual harassment she tweeted yes
governor cuomo sexually harassed me for
years
many saw it and watched i could never
anticipate what to expect would i be
grilled on my work which was very good
or harassed about my looks
or would it be both in the same
conversation this was the way for years
not knowing what to expect what's the
most upsetting part aside from knowing
that no one would do a damn thing even
when they saw it no one and i know i'm
not the only woman
i'm angry to be put in the situation of
all that because i'm a woman
i can work hard my whole life to better
myself and help others and yet still
fall victim as countless women over
generations have
mostly silently i hate that some men
like governor cuomo abuse their power
and this was as joe biden was apparently
considering cuomo for attorney
general so very very solid stuff i look
forward to the media reporting in detail
on these allegations just as they did
with brett kavanaugh with no evidence
other than christine blasey ford saying
things that could not be verified in any
way shape or form
here is uh what usa today reported here
is their headline you ready
the aid has not yet provided any
validating evidence for the allegations
or specified details on harassment
cuomo's office has denied the claim oh
that's
oh you see that's how you cover
allegations now i get it
so when somebody accuses brett kavanaugh
of gang rape
then you're like oh you know we should
probably do you know like put her on the
cover of magazines with her face made up
of words like they did on the cover of
time
that's probably what they should do but
when a lady accuses governor cuomo of
sexual harassment
you don't ask questions you don't try to
find other people in the office and ask
them if they ever saw evidence of it you
just say
well you know i guess we can move on
we're done here right
we're done here i look forward to chris
cuomo grilling his powerful brother
and speaking truth to power i also look
forward to the media really covering in
detail
in the fact that one of their favorite
senate candidates rafael warnock in
georgia
who is an anti-semite right i mean he's
done speeches defending jeremiah wright
over and over again
he did a speech in which he suggested
that jews were just shooting down
palestinians like quote unquote birds of
praise what he called the israelis
a real nice guy raphael warnock so just
to fight that anti-semitism he was
bringing down to campaign with him
ilhan omar rashida talib and linda
sarsour
now that's a solid way of fighting
anti-semitism is to bring in the three
most well-known anti-semites in america
outside of richard spencer it's a
campaign with you
real real really subtle right there what
he's doing raphael warnock
and i'm seeing the blanket coverage on
this right like i'm looking right now
i'm searching
sarsour warnock okay let's search the
news and let's see
how many people are covering the fact
that raphael warnock is bringing down to
campaign with him
a bunch of people who are radical
anti-semites
oh there well i see that um i see that
the jewish journal covered it and the
jewish telegraphic agency
covered it and um the washington times
covered it and that would be it that
would be the
complete list so really really solid
stuff everyone you're doing a great job
media-ing
your uh your your journalism is just
beyond
parallel meanwhile the hell speaking of
journalism beyond parallel listen to
this headline okay about kelly loffler
you think the media haven't taken sides
here
so kelly kelly lefler is running for a
senate in georgia she's the current
sitting senator of georgia
she shall act raphael warnock in their
debate you know that because people were
claiming that she had a bug in her ear
as soon as anybody says there's a wire
you know that person won the debate
anyway here is
sarah palace reporting for the hill
lefleur's campaign condemns white
supremacists to appear in photo that was
not their original headline
the original headline was leffler's
campaign refuses
or defends photo with white supremacist
that was their original headline they
changed the headline
editor's note the headline on the story
was updated at 8 45 pm to reflect that
senator lefler condemned chester dole's
white supremacist who posted a photo
with the senator
an earlier version of the story included
incorrect information wrong
an earlier version of this story had a
headline with incorrect information
in the story it said that lefleur
condemned the white supremacist and said
i take pictures of lots of people which
happens to be true right
as a quasi celeb i can tell you i take
lots of pictures of lots of people and
i'm sure there are lots of pictures of
people
who are unsavory because i've probably
taken at this point
producer colton can tell you because
he's traveled with me i've probably
taken easily 20 000 pictures of people
over the course of the last couple of
years
easily okay and i assume there's some of
those people who will go on to do
terrible things or who have done
terrible things in the past
okay so lefleur cracked back against it
and the hill reported that she had not
because that is how your wonderful media
work and then you wonder why people
don't trust the media like understand
that all the systemic distrust issues
that we are having right now over
election 2020
spur directly from gigantic mistrust of
the media
so when president trump says that nobody
trusts the media
when he says that you guys didn't even
follow up on the hunter biden stuff when
it was reported at the end of the
election he happens to be correct about
that
right this is what trump was saying over
the weekend he said listen
hunter biden joe lied about hunter from
the debate stage
this is true right joe biden said from
the debate stage there were not even any
allegations of hunter biden corruption
that is a lie that is not true
here was trump over the weekend pointing
this out the hunter biden this week
has confirmed two investigations on him
one on jim biden
you see the word is you're disappointed
that william barr knew about this in the
sword
everybody is who isn't disappointed
right joe biden lied on the debate stage
he said there's nothing happening
nothing happening and bill
barr should have stepped up okay and
trump happens to be correct
right trump happens to be correct the
media actively downplayed the story
and refused to report the story now of
course they can report the story
but when trump says that biden ran from
the basement he doesn't just mean that
biden stayed in the basement what he
means is nobody asked him a tough
question the entirety of the
presidential run
i said this early on now there are a lot
of people who say the election was
rigged because of voter fraud and voted
irregularity i haven't seen the evidence
to back that up
what i have seen is the clear evidence
that the media rigged the election
by refusing to cover any relevant
information about joe biden while
suggesting that donald trump
was responsible for hundreds of
thousands of dead people thanks to kovid
and that donald trump was a white
supremacist
who was in hock to russia that is how
you rig an election
okay seriously and so here's donald
trump pointing out that
biden ran a race from the basement was
able to get away with it
the spirit the liveliness the whole
thing even the fundraising the money
that's pouring in to fight this
it's one thing to say you know you ran a
great race
congratulations i'm okay with that but
they didn't
they didn't run a good race they were in
a horrible race from the basement they
ran a race
where he didn't even run okay so trump's
takeaway from that is that he couldn't
have lost because biden didn't run
the answer is the media ran i mean that
really is the answer the answer is not
that biden necessarily lost the vote
count because he
because he was jobs trump the answer is
that
donald trump was not right he was
correct about this he was not running
against joe biden primarily he was
running against a media
that wished to see him burn and is
willing to defend democrats and that's
not going to stop
okay if joe biden is inaugurated january
20th that is not going to end
it is not as though they go back to the
they go back to the business of
journalism
your mainstream media instead they get
into the business of targeting you
right trump is just the person that they
were attacking instead of you
now they'll get back to attacking you
the regular americans for whatever it is
you're doing today they'll dig up your
facebook post they'll dig up your
twitter they've got to fill that feed
somehow they've got to generate those
anger clicks from the left
so how are they going to do that they're
going to do that they don't have trump
to kick around anymore presumably
they'll still keep reporting on him even
if he's not president but they'll stop
they'll just turn and they'll go after
you
right that is the idea that red state
america is bad anybody who is a
republican is bad anybody who's a
conservative and meanwhile they will
ignore
actual breaking developments until it's
a little more convenient to cover them
speaking of which some breaking news on
the hunter biden story
so according to michael balsamo and eric
tucker
reporting for nbc philadelphia a
subpoena
seeking documents from hunter biden
asked for information related to more
than two dozen entities
including barisma according to a person
familiar with a justice department tax
investigation of president-elect joe
biden's son
the breadth of the subpoena issued
tuesday underscores the wide-angle lens
prosecutors are taking
as they examine the younger biden's
finances and international business
ventures
hunter biden's ties to barisma in
particular have long dogged the policy
work
and political aspirations of his father
joe biden now the president-elect of the
united states it's unclear
whether hunter's work at the ukrainian
company is a central part of the federal
investigation
or whether prosecutors are simply
seeking information about all his
sources of income
in recent years a lawyer for the younger
biden george messiahs did not
immediately return a phone call
seeking comment for the story a
spokesman for the biden transition team
declined
to comment hunter biden said he only
learned of the investigation
last tuesday but of course that's number
one it may be true but that
investigation was launched apparently in
2018. by the way i share
trump's ire that the doj didn't announce
this investigation was going on
i understand there's such a thing as a
covert versus an over investigation
but the difference between a covert and
an overt investigation is mainly public
knowledge of the investigation going on
now there are reports back in october
that hunter was under investigation
it would have been very easy for the doj
to confirm or deny that story they
didn't
instead they held out until past the
election saying that it fulfilled their
mandate not to interfere in an election
well it's already public knowledge that
an investigation is going on and then
you just keep it quiet until after the
election that is in fact election
interference
the younger biden joined the board of
barisma in 2014 around the time his
daddy then vp was helping conduct the
obama administration's foreign policy
with ukraine
and this is my favorite president trump
and his allies have long argued without
evidence that hunter biden's work in
ukraine influenced the obama
administration's policies
toward the eastern european nation well
that's not all they argued they also
argued that hunter was clearly taking
advantage of daddy's name in order to
get the job
and that joe almost certainly knew about
that okay that is a lot harder to argue
against
in announcing the process in february
with regard to collecting information on
ukraine
william barr the ag cautioned the
department had to be careful about any
information
coming from ukraine of course but it is
true the federal investigation had been
ongoing we also now know according to
the washington examiner
that a former business partner of hunter
biden reportedly said in an email biden
didn't disclose hundreds of thousands of
dollars in income on his tax returns
eric schwerin former president of
rosemont seneca partners sent an email
to biden in 2017
saying he needed to amend his 2014 tax
returns to include about 400 grand in
income
he made as a member of burisma the email
says in 2014 you joined the burisma
board we still need to amend your 2014
returns
to reflect the unreported buries my
income as according to an email
dated january 16 2017 the email
reportedly notes that biden
the son of joe made 1.2 million bucks in
income when factoring in the 400 grand
he made
as board member of burisma nbc noted it
didn't have access to the hard drive
apparently this email was provided
by rudy giuliani's attorney robert
costello who had gotten the hunter hard
drive from that computer repair store
in delaware so presumably now the media
will cover this sort of stuff
because now they think it's over but you
wonder why
people don't trust the system it's
because the media to so many people are
the system
right the media are the glasses with
which you view the information and if it
turns out those glasses are broken
people aren't going to trust the
information behind the glasses
just like in poker very often you see
players wearing sunglasses so you can't
read their eyes
well if the media are sunglasses for the
democratic party agenda
how can you trust what's behind the
sunglasses there's no way to trust
what what is behind the sunglasses okay
speaking of which over the weekend
there were some there was some dust up
in washington dc in which four people
were stabbed 33 people arrested
there was a violent clash between
pro-trump activists and suspected
members of antifa in washington dc
on saturday night following a rally for
the president's supporters this is
according to emily's inaudible daily
wire
thousands attended the rally on saturday
according to local media calling for a
halt
to certifying some states presidential
election results pending investigations
into what some believe to be widespread
voter fraud efforts aimed at helping
biden
a suspected borrowing brawl between
pro-trump demonstrators and anti-trump
activists which took place following the
march
turned into a violent conflict between
the two factions at per fox news
the outlet noted chaos erupted in
washington d.c on saturday night
hours after two after two pro-trump
rallies ended
groups of proud boys and antifa
activists clashed under cover of
darkness with police repeatedly forcing
them apart
amid reports of brawls and stabbings at
least four stabbings occurred near a bar
that served as a gathering spot for the
proud boys the victims were hospitalized
possibly with life-threatening injury
injuries a dc fire department
spokesperson told the newspaper
okay so that is where things currently
stand it's not clear who
the aggressor was uh it is fair to say
that everywhere antifa goes there is
violence
and there have been a number of
incidents with the proud boys as well
obviously
the two groups apparently were lobbying
fireworks at each other before engaging
in close quarters combat and the police
ultimately deployed pepper spray to
control both sides of the altercation so
ugly stuff
uh on on all sides there obviously
okay meanwhile today is the day that the
electoral college is supposed to vote
here is how that process
works the vote begins or began this
morning at
10 a.m eastern time it continues through
the day each state goes through the
process
apparently it's going to be broadcast
and live streamed
now according to the constitution
electors that meet by law they meet by
law on the first monday after the second
wednesday in december that's supposed to
give you enough time to resolve any
disputes regarding the november
third election the electors then meet in
places across the country
very often in the state legislatures and
then each of the 538 electors cast a
vote for president and one for vice
president
as well there are laws in 32 states and
the district of columbia they require
electors to vote for the candidate who
won the popular vote in their state
there's 17 in a state
17 states that allow so-called faithless
electors to vote for
their choice but that is extremely
extremely rare
the electoral votes are then counted by
the house and senate on january 6th that
is when the house and senate certify
the vote it is highly unlikely it will
be stopped in congress once all the
electoral college votes have actually
been
sent in and that is particularly true
because the supreme court
knocked down that big texas case that
was pending last week we talked in
length about it on friday
i thought there were serious problems
legally speaking with the texas case if
you were going to overturn results of
the elections
you actually have to show voter fraud
and voter irregularity you can't merely
suggest that the process itself is
flawed and certainly you have to have
standing to sue
in other words you have to be a party
inside the states you cannot simply
allege that another party inside a state
that is not your own
is performing some sort of sin that
opens the door wide to serious
violations of federalism principles
you can see california suing texas based
on texas abortion law saying
you're throwing people to california to
have abortions that causes taxpayer
resources to be used out here
and therefore we're going to sue texas
for its implementation of roe vs wade
for example
that is not a principle you want to see
applied broadly speaking
the court killed any chance that uh that
lawsuit would move forward
the order rejected texas's attempt to
nullify the results in four other states
the decision i believe was nine nothing
the uh so thomas and alito
uh voted issued a statement that that
point that that suggested
that states should have an unfair right
to sue each other directly at the
supreme court they said they would have
at least let texas file the suit
but saying that they would have let
texas file the suit doesn't mean they
would have let texas win the suit
so that that is more of a legal issue as
to as far as original jurisdictions
there's a question in the constitution
if a state sues another state in federal
court does the supreme court have to
hear it because
original jurisdiction now goes directly
to the supreme court they don't have to
work their way up the chain do does the
supreme court have to take the case
alito and thomas basically said
yeah we think the supreme court has to
take the case seven of the other
justices said no
they don't have to take the case but
that is an ancillary question to how
that case would have done at the supreme
court
thomas and alito also said they would
reject texas's request to stop
the four pivotal states from casting
their votes for biden no justice said
that he or she would have blocked those
votes
it was a pretty straightforward decision
in in the same way that that
that pennsylvania case was a
straightforward 9-0 decision
when you have nine zero decisions it's
usually a pretty clear-cut decision
legally speaking
beyond that there's a wisconsin case
that was pending and it turns out that
team trump was just not making the sort
of allegations that are likely to result
in the change to the election i know
these are uncomfortable facts but
uncomfortable facts they may be they're
still facts
andy mccarthy points out over a national
review
that there is a federal district court
rejection of another trump campaign
lawsuit on saturday it was
the the sort of last lawsuit that was
pending
number one the rejecting was done by a
trump appointed judge
okay one of the one of the passages in
the decision according to andy
mccarthy's worthy of note
he says with the electoral college
meeting just days away the court
declined to address the issues in
piecemeal fashion
and instead provided plaintiff with an
expedited hearing on the merits of the
claim
on the morning of the hearing the
parties reached agreement on a
stipulated set of facts and then
presented arguments to the court okay so
normally
what that means that the court was
saying to team trump okay show me all
your evidence of voter fraud and voter
regularity like
now put it out we got to expedite this
thing give me your they got their chance
to put it in court
instead team trump stipulated that they
agreed that there was no spread there
was no widespread voter fraud or voter
irregularity evidence
if they stipulated and agreed to that in
court
as andy mccarthy points out a stipulated
set of facts in this context is an
agreement between the lawyers for the
adversary parties
about what testimony witnesses would
give and or what facts would be
established if the parties
went through the process of calling
witnesses and offering tangible evidence
at a hearing or trial
in a real controversy in which one or
both of the parties are making hotly
disputed factual claims
there are almost no stipulations for
example a defendant who vehemently
denies that he committed stock fraud may
be willing to stipulate
that 20 000 shares of a common stock
were sold
but other than that the defendant will
demand adversary call fact witnesses
who claim he defrauded them so he can
cross examine them but here the trump
campaign has been claiming extensive
voter fraud and law breaking and then
they stipulated a agreement to the basic
facts with democrats
so what did they say the case was really
about if it wasn't about voter fraud and
voter irregularity three differences
over the manner in which the election
was administered
to all of which as as the judge pointed
out the campaign could have objected
before the election
if the matters had actually been of
great moment
so it turns out that the the legal
strategy in wisconsin was deeply flawed
as well
and so that means that the electoral
college is going to move forward with
its vote today that is not a particular
shock
worth noting here that all of the
members of the media have been screaming
and crying about the violation
of critical voting protocol should note
that the process worked here
okay and it worked to their favor okay
the record cases filed the court cases
were
nearly all dismissed team trump's legal
strategy went 1 and 53
something like that like one win and
some 50 some losses
okay that georgia case i believe is
still pending with regard to voter fraud
voter irregularity that's the only
serious
case still on the docket we'll see why
they have the
the proof to push that through meanwhile
the same people
are promoting the idea that it is deeply
undemocratic to file lawsuits
or wonder about voter fraud and voter
irregularity
are completely ignoring the fact that
democrats have now been requested by a
democrat to overturn the results of an
election in iowa
according to the des moines register in
iowa's second congressional district
rita hart
the loser by six votes to marianne
miller meeks has picked a path that will
inflame
her team skipped the appeal process
available through iowa's courts and
instead elected to petition
the u.s house of representatives panel
directly to oversee a recount before the
full house decides the outcome
so basically she's asking the democrats
in congress to overturn the results of
the election
through their procedures and then take
the seat back
okay that's just as undemocratic as
anything the democrats are accusing
republicans of it's just not getting any
of the same sort of media coverage
number one because it's a congressional
grace but number two
because it is a democrat which is always
worthy of note
okay meanwhile and some actual good news
the coveted vaccine is going out
on mass today tons of doses going out
today
which is excellent excellent news of
course and um
the bioentech head you've worked on the
worked on the vaccine he says that we
should be getting back to normal by the
end of next summer because at that point
all the vaccines are out there and
life is what life is we know that we
have a solution
yeah and we know that we can produce
many doses of vaccines and we know that
there
will be also other vaccines which have
shown efficacy
and therefore therefore people
we should be confident that we can we we
will be able to control this disease and
the pandemic
latest end of next summer that is dr
uger
sahin who is one of the heads of a
bioentech which worked with pfizer to
develop the vaccine
2.9 million doses of covid19 vaccine are
beginning to arrive
uh a lot of those are going to the most
populous places in the country
so first in line our 17 million
healthcare workers and 3.7 million
nursing home residents
and then you get essential workers
teachers first responders and then you
get
89 million people with pre-existing
conditions now
here's the thing i think that probably
we should actually be working on people
with pre-existing conditions first if
you're an essential worker
but you're 25 years old and healthy you
really should not be in line before
somebody who is 65 years old
and has serious preexisting conditions
so the tranching doesn't make a whole
hell of a lot of sense
nonetheless uh this is the way that the
distribution is
going to go and the number of doses
varies
fairly widely by state in the early
going california is about to get
330 000 doses colorado's gonna get 47
000 doses
but smaller states are going to get far
fewer delaware only gets about 9 000
doses
florida gets 180 000 doses so the the
the vaccines have begun to roll out that
is a massive win
for the trump administration the media
however
are suggesting that it is the trump
administration's fault that people are
skeptical about about the vaccine
because there's a lot of questions about
who wants to take the vaccine
and let me be clear the vaccine in terms
of the studies has been proved to be
effective
does that mean that children should be
getting it probably not at least not as
at first blush they should be like last
in line
number one because they are at least
risk of this thing and number two
because they are the least likely to
transmit this thing or have
intergenerational contact with people
who are elderly as i say we should be
tranching this thing out
and you know people should be able to
assess their own
level of risk when it comes to getting
the thing versus not getting the thing
or damage if you do get the thing as
opposed to not getting the thing if
you're
17 years old and you're not only
unlikely to die of this thing it's less
likely to kill you than the flu
you may be like well not sure i'm into
it that's understandable
with that said the widespread vaccine
skepticism that has now cropped up on
the left is clearly a product of the
media hating trump
now the media are going to turn around
try and blame trump for the vaccine
skepticism they themselves created
on msnbc here we go they were blaming
trump for blue state vaccine skepticism
yeah yes and unfortunately this happened
because of just the
horrible precedent they got set by
the president and members of the trump
administration
to politicize a number of treatments
and even some of the efforts leading to
a vaccine to this point
okay that is dr kavita patel a former
obama official obviously so it's about
politicization never mind the fact that
everybody in the process says the
process was never politicized
in fact the united states lagged behind
two other countries the uk and canada
where the third country to actually
approve the distribution of the vaccine
here's the fda chief in fact saying
external pressure was not the issue in
us
deciding to green light this thing
jake we have been very clear and and
i'll say it again here
that nothing guided our decision no
external comments
no external pressure other than the
science and data guided
our decision making if you look at the
timetable here
immediately after the vaccine advisory
committee
our team spent that night we decided to
go forward and you know by
early morning before 7am we issued a
statement saying that we were moving
forward working with pfizer to get the
authorization out
and then we worked throughout the day to
do that our timeline
how we approached this was based upon
our thorough review
of the science and data that's the
promise we made the american people
the transparency around that and that's
what we did so we're just going to
whitewash completely the fact that
andrew cuomo and kamala harris and a
bunch of democrats were casting
absolute doubt on the efficacy of the
vaccine developed under the trump
administration instead we're going to
pretend that it was trump putting
pressure on the fda
i mean like the media's malfeasance with
regard to covet is the reason that
people have serious covet
trust issues with regard to solving this
thing another reason is because there
are so many people who seem to be
in the media eager to shut this thing
down i mean just super eager to shut
down
the economy like really eager to talk
about
how bad things are going to be for years
on end so bill gates who has
given a lot of money to the development
of vaccines like this one bill gates
went on national tv with jake tapper
where he explained that life would not
return to normal
through 2022 2022
and then we should not open bars and
restaurants for four to six months
that's easy for bill gates to say he's
one of the richest people on earth how
about the people who actually own those
restaurants
2022 are you kidding me here's how this
is actually gonna work
once the vaccines go out and once we've
given the possibility of dosing to
everybody
everybody's going back to work and
people are not gonna wear masks they're
not gonna do it forever they're not that
interested in doing this for a long time
they're just not it's not gonna happen
but the the sort of
blithe dismissal bill gates has for
normality is pretty incredible
of course it's easy to do that when you
are you know jetting around on private
jets and living on private islands
here's bill gates certainly by the
summer
we'll be way closer to normal than we
are now
but even through early 2022 unless we
help other countries
get rid of this disease and we get high
vaccination rates in our country
the risk of reintroduction will be there
and of course
the global economy will be uh slowed
down which hurts
america economically in a pretty
dramatic way
so we'll have starting the summer about
nine months where a few things like big
public gatherings
uh will still be restricted but
you know we can see now that somewhere
between 12 to 18 months
and we have a chance if we manage it
well uh to get back to normal
nope wrong watch once everybody has the
opportunity to get vaccinated
and then the people who want to do we're
going back to normal
okay and nobody's going to pay attention
to what bill gates has to say about any
of this
and this is true with regard to asking
it is true with regard to everyday
activity nobody is going to stay away
from their families
by the way a huge percentage of the
spread is not in public events it is
family gatherings
so if we are it's not it's not these big
super spreader events that are the real
danger really
it is people who have covet going back
home to mom and dad people are not going
to put off life
for another two years not happening not
happening
all righty we'll be back here later
today for two additional hours
of the ben shapiro show while you wait
check out the matt wall show it's
streaming on daily wire
10 30 a.m pacific time 1 30 pm eastern
today he'll be discussing united
airlines kicking a family off their
flight because their two-year-old
wouldn't wear a mask
by the way quick note on that story
two-year-olds are not gonna wear masks
and you should not be kicked off a
flight because your two-year-old won't
wear a mask that's insane
okay but beyond that i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica crand
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2020.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clinton